[Música]
hola hola buenas tardes con todos este
me da un gusto estar aquí en la
universidad y bueno quiero compartirles
algo a ver si nos en este contexto de la
cosmovisión hablamos de algo de
tecnología la pregunta es quién usa
tecnología aquí no quiero ver
a veces tenemos hasta exceso de
tecnología verdad entonces yo quisiera
mostrarles un poquito respecto a que
estamos viviendo no es cierto el ser
humano sobre todo lo que le interesa es
trabajar y para eso quiere mover las
cosas y hacer las cosas más rápido
correcto y en ese sentido siempre usa
algo en que ayudarse y primero el hombre
para trabajar uso sus manos y de esa
forma logró sus objetivos pero como todo
en esta vida a veces lo manual cuesta
trabajo se comenzó a tratar de ver cómo
ahorrar energía cómo hacer que su fuerza
se multiplique y eso es lo que dio lugar
a la primera revolución industrial que
en este caso aparece donde el hombre usa
un elemento importante que es el vapor y
en base al vapor se hace una revolución
donde se mueven las cosas más rápidas y
el símbolo del vapor es de la locomotora
y sirve la locomotora precisamente para
ver que ese movimiento movía la economía
movía las relaciones humanas y todo lo
que nosotros a nuestro alrededor vemos
pasa más o menos un siglo
y de alguna forma la siguiente fuerza es
la electricidad y el invento de la
electricidad logra lo que al hombre le
dé potencia en muchos aspectos le
permite aumentar más horas le permite
mover más máquinas le permite que con la
luz se produzca la producción en masa
pasan otros siglos más o menos para 1969
se produce una revolución tan fuerte por
el invento de los chips o sea se siente
más fuerte en ese año que había pasado
en años anteriores se había inventado el
transistor y el transistor el hombre ya
había logrado dominar las fuerzas pero
le interesaba ahora que el control se
puede hacer mucho mejor manera el
control de aparatos del control de todo
lo que vemos y ese control de alguna
manera lo hizo en base a unos y ceros y
estos unos y ceros de alguna forma lo
que lograron
el hombre tengas amplifica sus
capacidades y esto sirvió para modificar
muchas de las cosas que hoy vemos hasta
el día de hoy pero no nos podíamos
quedar en esa tercera revolución
industrial sino que aparecería la cuarta
y saben que ustedes son de esa
generación que están viviendo casi
algunos vivimos dos generaciones de
revolución porque estas revoluciones han
sido muy rápido pero ustedes se dice ya
voy a explicar un poquito más que
estamos ya en esa cuarta revolución
industrial que tiene que ver
fundamentalmente con la capacidad del
hombre para manejar todo lo que hace con
tecnologías exponenciales sí sobre todo
algoritmos es decir el hombre quiere
crear su símil ok y en ese sentido en
cada una de estas revoluciones que nos
encontramos fundamentalmente toma toma
tomamos de atención a que la capacidad
de procesamiento es lo que de alguna
manera está embebida en esto y esa
capacidad de procesamiento el hombre
haya usado artificios muy interesantes
para que esa capacidad de procesamiento
se emulan primero con tarjetas luego con
unos con los unos reales
recuerden que todo estaba en crear una
similitud a los unos y ceros y después
de eso aparecieron los bulbos que
también si militaban unos y ceros y cada
vez la capacidad que ustedes están
viendo aumentaba esa capacidad de
procesamiento y se desdoblaba en el 69
prácticamente y estábamos teniendo una
capacidad de que el pensamiento o el
procesamiento ya tenía era inversamente
proporcional al costo es decir ya
comenzaba a disminuir y cada vez y cada
vez aumenta 2 que consecuencia tiene
esto la consecuencia de esto es que los
elementos que ahora tenemos allá en los
en los años 60 70 la computación
comienza en los 40 y ustedes con ustedes
hay una película que se llama código
enigma ese es realmente el origen del
primer gran computador
y miren los tamaños de los aparatos que
teníamos eran muy grandes y con esta
capacidad del hombre de los circuitos
electrónicos tenemos cosas si ustedes
sacan su teléfono a alguien se le ha
ocurrido a abrirle y es algo pequeñito
realmente verdad y en ese sentido que es
lo que pasa a cada rato les invito a que
vean este vídeo que es lo que ha pasado
en la en el contexto de la evolución
desde los 80 hasta el día de hasta el 14
por ahí en donde esta tercera revolución
ha ocasionado que todos se digitalice
todo se democratice todo sea disruptivo
de alguna manera ustedes muchos de aquí
porque piensa que clara la mayoría de
acá son muy jóvenes no han de haber
visto esto pero de verdad que existía
todo a mano se recortaba se hacía todo
lo que es y al final todo lo que están
viendo allí se ha digitalizado
pregúntele a su papá ya su abuelitos
cómo era su escritorio y hoy digamos
sólo necesitamos apenas un teléfono
verdad y eso es eso es lo que ha pasado
cada minuto que pasa con esta tercera
revolución de la informática tuvo su
digamos estamos en esa en esa mitad
donde aparecen lo que pasa cada minuto
y adicionalmente estamos en la cuarta
revolución estamos justo en el momento
donde cambia de una revolución a otra y
solo para ver una cosa netflix en un año
pasó de 70 mil horas vistas a 266 mil
horas buenas a las series
pero eso es porque tenemos esa capacidad
para hacer las cosas que hemos visto
también por ejemplo otro ejemplo las
fotos han pasado de 46 mil fotos por
minuto a casi 174 mil fotos por minuto
que pintas de nosotros no el self y si
toman en cuenta otras otras cosas por
acá en la mensajería por ejemplo a
mensajería de facebook de 15 mil a 25
mil y no tengo datos en estas láminas de
whatsapp pero todo el guasave es todavía
mucho peor el incremento de todo y hay
nuevos actores como por ejemplo ustedes
bueno no han de saber qué es kinder no
pero mire que el crecimiento de manches
si se ríen yo no sé pero bueno también
aparecen nuevos actores el manejo de voz
el amazon eco los dos amazon con cuantos
nuevos aplicaciones han comenzado a
aparecer 67 por minuto es decir órdenes
no y alguien conoce twitch
claro ustedes son gamers eso eso de
alguna manera también son nuevas
influencias de 936.000 y pico por minuto
eso que ustedes ven está sucediendo
ahora
y eso cuando aparece está está esta
revista economics y aparece todo lo que
se llama este dibujo y dicen la tercera
revolución industrial cuando en realidad
sí cuenta en 1234 en realidad luego le
conocen como revolución 4.0 que se
manifiesta como la capacidad del hombre
tiene nuevamente para ahorrar energía y
para crear cosas a partir de la
informática y usando tecnologías hace
alusión a la impresión 3d y ahí comienza
la revolución que básicamente es una
convergencia de los dos mundos de los
mundos físicos biológicos y digitales
sino fíjense en su cuerpo y el teléfono
es parte de uno y hay implantes y hay
cosas en fin
esto está transformando este momento en
la humanidad
yo siempre digo en pocas palabras que es
la cuarta revolución industrial la
intersección entre el mundo offline y el
mundo online
y bueno
con esta cuarta cuarta revolución
aparecen tecnologías potentes
tecnologías que son exponenciales que
dan lugar a economías exponenciales que
dan lugar a la economías colaborativas
que dan lugar a economías naranjas en
fin
y aparece por ejemplo las comunicaciones
en los teléfonos 5g o lo que llamamos
del internet de alta velocidad que más
aparece el internet de las cosas y de
las nano cosas es decir todo el mundo
ahora está rodeado de sensores ustedes
no se dan cuenta pero tienen sensores su
propio teléfono está censando por donde
te mueves por dónde te va etcétera
hoy en día lo que más vale en las
empresas no es los activos es los datos
es el tema de la información de los
datos la big data
y tenemos la revolución de los
materiales hoy se puede imprimir todo
incluyendo órganos con compuestos
especiales y hay un material muy
interesante que tengo la experiencia de
tener una una iniciativa el grafeno
entonces el grafeno es aquello que no
vemos en las películas que las las
ventanas se doblan o son más duros que
el acero el ironman y todo eso que vemos
básicamente eso es la consecuencia del
grafeno más fuerte que el acero más
conductor los chips ya dejan de ser de
silicio y aparecen el grafeno es un
compuesto que que te puede te puede
permite pensar más rápidamente cosas y
con cosas chiquitas en fin
y la inteligencia artificial ni que
decir ustedes tienen componentes en sus
teléfonos y usan iphone city si usan
otro lo que sea y es una forma de
inteligencia artificial solo para
lenguaje natural porque hay muchas cosas
más que en este tema la biotecnología
del adn
quieres tener hojas verdes que tu hijo
tenga ojos verdes podemos hacer algo no
y si el papá es bien feo no
este en ese sentido la robótica también
hay muchas muchas empresas como boston
robots que cada vez los vídeos que suben
y que manejan son realmente
impresionantes de como la capacidad del
robot ya es prácticamente humana para
cargar para manipular en fin los vuelos
espaciales ustedes se han preguntado
alguna vez por qué van la gente al
espacio para que le digan ves qué bueno
qué buen tipo lo logró no porque arriba
y fácilmente materiales hay oro hay
titanio hay formas de vida poder poder
vivir si también en casa una emergencia
de un poder de nuestro planeta sufra
algo malo
autos autónomos y eléctricos ya es una
realidad en quito y hay algunos autos
autónomos en quito con los taxistas y
todo eso no sé pero de que algún rato
tendremos tendremos drones drones para
todo tipo de cosas
el blog en alguien escuchado del blog
y unos poquitos bueno ya luego les
explico que es básicamente en esencia
esto va a cambiar muchas relaciones de
interacción del intercambio del valor es
una tecnología para que una red valide
transacciones en resumen y lo que más se
conoce desde sus aplicaciones como por
ejemplo el bitcoin y la script o monedas
así como aplicaciones que hay en este
contexto que ya vamos a ver al final que
puede que qué es lo que está afectando y
todo fundamentalmente esto está
generando cambios en la economía cambios
en las formas de trabajo porque el blog
sem en una manera en puras palabras es
el sistema operativo de la verdad o el
sistema operativo de la confianza
y energía renovable tantas formas del
hombre está tratando de replantearse su
consumo de su matriz energética y se
están creando nuevos elementos y ahí
entra también el grafeno
yo le digo cómputo en visión en donde ya
toda la realidad y la realidad comienzan
a ser irrelevantes desde el punto de
vista de las aplicaciones que se tiene
y yo les puedo decir tantas otras
tecnologías que se vienen y que según
hay computadores cuánticos hay biochips
bueno ahí pueden ustedes ver la cantidad
de tecnologías que están en la curva de
innovación en las expectativas y este es
este gráfico que ven saca cada año
garner para ver cuáles son las
tendencias sobre las cuales la
tecnología está
y la pregunta mayor de todas si es cómo
está afectando esto la tecnología como
cuál es la cosmovisión de la tecnología
es un amigo es un enemigo nos va a
quitar cosas nos va a agregar cosas ese
es el gran cuestionamiento que tenemos
que ver y en ese sentido
hay muchas afectaciones
la primera de ellas es la economía
en la economía fundamentalmente hay
muchas disrupciones en cuanto a estas
tecnologías entran guía y cambian las
matrices en económicas por ejemplo el
caso del blogs en tenemos la capacidad
de intercambiar valores a través de esta
red que funciona en donde siempre hay un
intermediario en toda relación de cambio
de valor yo te vendo algo tú me das algo
pero qué quiere en realidad le haces le
haces un pago con un billete quien
respalda el billete un banco central o
por ejemplo no te voy a pagar con cheque
quien respalda el cheque el banco o por
ejemplo voy a comprarte la casa como
sabes que la propiedad es real o no le
intercambias de propiedad y le das a uno
u otro siempre hay un
alguien intermediario que va guardando
el registro de tengo tanto debo tanto
tengo tanto debo tanto etcétera ese
registro lo mantiene una entidad
centralizada pero que a alguien se le
ocurrió con un seudónimo satoshi
nakamoto dijo bueno esto no está bien
invento un protocolo que se llama
bitcoin y el protocolo dice que en una
red
todos pueden tener el registro del
intercambio y que significa el registro
al intercambio que cada uno de ustedes
tendría el mismo registro por lo tanto
no hay necesidad del intermediario creen
que eso puede cambiar las condiciones
económicas definitivamente sí y la
muestra es que el bitcoin no ha muerto y
está justamente como una como un
elemento de creación de valor y se está
intercambiando en que está basado el bit
coin
en nada no hay nada habrá un billete
ahorita de ustedes los que tengan en su
mano y digan lo que dice su billete de
un dólar y si no tienen un billete de un
dólar de cinco si no tiene plata vean el
de al lado pero vean lo dice res nota de
la reserva federal si no está no sea ni
siquiera es valor y al reverso dice en
que está basado nosotros confiamos en
dios
en otras palabras está basado en la fe
porque no está basado en el oro no está
basado en nada lo mismo pero el bitcoin
y la economía de este sentido comienza a
generar una serie de elementos en donde
bueno ya como ya salió el bitcoin y
todos quieren hacer su moneda entonces
ahora las monedas se respaldan en algo
por ejemplo si se produce grafeno la
producción del grafeno se puede
convertir en una moneda porque hay una
paridad sobre algo
también hay los elementos relacionados
con los intercambios de algo entonces tú
le das algo y recibes algo y en vez de
entregarle una moneda o un papel un
pagaré le entregas un token y comienza
el tema de la toque nización de los
activos esas cosas hacen que también
haya nuevas relaciones de negocio en
cuanto a
e intercambio de valor por ejemplo ya
los fideicomisos no tendrían razón de
ser la intermediación de las bolsas de
valores tampoco pero como los que están
intermediarios ed se dan cuenta de esto
pues ellos dicen si no puedes con ellos
pues simplemente únete los y comienzan a
usar las tecnologías los bancos las
empresas de gobierno todo lo que
intermedia para lograr este tema y ese
es el tema de las afectaciones
principalmente de esto en la economía
además de otras que por tiempo pues
pasaré la educación
como ya estuvo aquí santiago la
educación es libertad pero afecta
también muchas de las cosas de la
educación como por ejemplo y estoy
totalmente de acuerdo con la libertad el
problema es que el conocimiento se hace
obsoleto demasiado rápido lo que ustedes
aprenden en la universidad en pocos
meses
es obsoleto consecuencia de lo cual es
lo que pasa en el tema de la educación
la educación tiene que estar acorde con
esta capacidad de enseñarnos a aprender
y en base a skills sobre skills
y capacidades para emprender enseñar ese
tipo de cosas para lograr cosas por
ejemplo de aquí quién quiere ser
empleado
nadie increíble
y ninguno en otra en otra charla una
sola mano y ahora ustedes nadie entonces
que debemos aprender a aprender a
emprender y eso es una connotación qué
pasa con estas tecnologías si estas
tecnologías le pones dentro de la
educación las cosas cambian brutalmente
si entonces esta es otra implicación y
por supuesto la la aplicación del
trabajo qué pasa con el trabajo muchos
se sienten amenazados por los trabajos y
hay críticas porque dicen por ejemplo se
dice que en los próximos años el 90% de
los abogados desaparecerán quién es
quien está estudiando leyes mi hijo
también aquí
ya le dije pero pero entonces la
pregunta la pregunta es y por qué bueno
va a haber necesidad de abogados
especialistas así que tienen que ser
realmente buenos en un campo entonces en
ese sentido el trabajo se siente
afectado pero también de acuerdo a un
estudio del g20 se dice que estas
tecnologías crean 3.2 veces más trabajos
que actuales y si no bajamos un ejemplo
sencillo para que lo entendamos qué pasó
con la la segunda revolución
ustedes se daban cuenta de alguna manera
que en 1893 se inventó el auto en
alemania y hay una foto en el internet
en donde dice esta es la avenida
pensilvania y en la avenida pensilvania
de nueva york había todos llenos de
caballos en los 1900 y sólo había un
auto
13 años más tarde
había solo un caballo
y restaurantes así es como se aumentan
este tipo de cosas y este tipo de la
situación la pregunta es y los trabajos
de esa pobre gente que estuvo ahí
pues miren había para frenos había gente
que alimentaba no había un montón de ese
tipo de personas la pregunta que yo les
hago es qué pasa después de que aparece
el auto se pudieron crear nuevos empleos
como por ejemplo que preparadores de
autos mecánicos repuestos etcétera
etcétera conclusión se crean
oportunidades no las dejen de ver
obviamente en otra forma y en otro
contexto tienen que entender que eso hay
que estudiar distinto para lograr
entender y capacitarse de eso se dice
que ustedes como los milenios que viene
acá ustedes cambiarán de trabajo 7 veces
si siete veces de los cuales cinco son
trabajos que aún no existen
entonces pueden dar la afectación usted
están estudiando para algo o para
emprender algo que aún a lo mejor no
existe y si inventan algo que no existe
va a ser una startup exitosa y va a ser
algo interesante que puede ser de
crecimiento exponencial
finalmente el marco regulatorio no
alcanzará a a cooperar tan rápido cómo
van estas tecnologías
y lo social ni les digo la democracia
será más democracia el hombre tendrá más
capacidad es para criticar pero también
los gobiernos tendrán más capacidades
para controlar controlar como lo hacen
ya en china donde por tu cara sabes que
estás aquí qué has hecho y tal entonces
son tantas cosas que podría quedarme
aquí toda la tarde pero yo les quiero
agradecer y bueno ahí estando ahí está
el twitter en caso que tenga preguntas
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]